al inicio del año 2022 el gobierno
panameño informó que habría logrado un
acuerdo con la empresa cobre Panamá
filial de la canadiense de First Quantum
y que ese acuerdo le garantizaba el
estado panameño ingresos anuales de más
de 300 millones de dólares más un
incremento importante de las regalías
que pasarían de 2% de los ingresos
brutos a más del 12% solo se esperaba la
elaboración del contrato y la firma sin
embargo ese proceso se extendió el
gobierno fijó como plazo el pasado 14 de
diciembre y al no concretar se anunció
el cierre de las operaciones comerciales
de la minera alegando que esta medida se
basa en los intereses nacionales en
Panamá algunos consideran que esta
acción fue tardía Pues el contrato que
le garantizaba operaciones a la empresa
hasta 2037 había sido declarado como
inconstitucional 2018 por la Corte
Suprema de Justicia por otro lado hay
quienes tienen dudas sobre lo que
ocurrirá en adelante el futuro de los
empleados y el impacto económico para el
país pues esta mina representa una de
las mayores inversiones privadas en
Panamá más de seis mil millones de
dólares además contribuía con el 4% del
producto interno bruto